the Joe Rogan experience I think you've
done a great job doing it your way I
really and I I salute that and I also
like you know Joe you've had a big hand
in my career and in what's gone on with
honey honey and how you've supported us
and like there's something very special
about not just just doing your weight
not tailoring it to anyone elses agenda
it's like it's pretty [ __ ] cool what
you're doing my friend but the crazy
thing is that it happened a hundred
percent organically you know there was
no preconception there was no idea this
was gonna happen just keep doing it and
do what you like and then eventually it
happens but like when you and I want to
see Sturgill how fun was that so good
how fun was that good but I enjoyed that
so much because like we went to see what
another one of our friends and there's
like real cool intimate setting I don't
know Sturgill you worked with him never
met him there was some communication we
so we both worked with Dave Cobb on
honey honey's last record was produced
by Dave Cobb and he does all of sergel's
records for the most things crazy I
would have swore that you guys had met
no I've never met him a huge fan loved
him but I told you I got mad at him at
one point where he did like an 11-minute
guitar so I was [ __ ] sick and then he
said hmm alright it's a little too much
testosterone let's tone it down for the
ladies and he played like a like a love
song and I was like he was just looking
for a good segue man I loved him
[Applause]